my name is peter pan and welcome to
finally being a
[Music]
my name and welcome to I can only do on
hangers I'm the microphone it's been a
great week I actually was bro army was
actually one of the highest growing
channels on YouTube this week I'm real
proud of you bros I'm glad that things
are hitting it off so well if you're not
familiar with Friday's with people
before it's basically my weekly check-in
with you bros oh it's for you bros it's
for my subscribe two weeks ago I had a
song contest and the winner is finally
announced I know I always have to do a
dramatic face whenever there so it
should know okay I was probably more
like creepy face Hey there was a lot of
really awesome submissions I got over
200 of them I feel sad that I have to
choose one because there were so many of
them that deserve to be a winner but the
winner is there's seriously only pony
I'll be uploading the you'll find a link
in the description to the song it's
really awesome thanks for all the
awesome fana that you submitted to the
video it's really a video that you may
like I didn't do anything
you rose made the art you bros made the
music I would really want to thank you
for all the things that you do for me it
really means a lot I started a second
channel now it's called Beauty it's my
old old old old old old account I
finally got the password back it's gonna
be non horror game play on it I felt
like there's a lot of times I want to
play a game I'm not sure if it's good
enough for now so I don't know I can
experiment right now I'm thinking about
playing Skyrim and limbo I have those
two series running on that channel so
that's something that strikes your fancy
go over there and subscribe link is in
description or gives user comments like
me for those who you are curious about
my second chests my vlog channel I had a
lot of trouble with Google head
since on that account they are very
strict with their rules and violation
without which I was very well aware of
so I've been extremely cautious not to
violate their terms but somehow I don't
even know what the [ __ ] happened but
they accuse me of fraud took all the
money I made from that amount for no
reason at all so I've been trying to fix
it but it doesn't look like it's gonna
be fixed some to be honest it sucks but
what can you do I hope I am more lucky
with this accounts I can finally get
going start with me these I'm really
excited about it I really hope you bros
join me with a little non horror
gameplay as soon as I uploaded my show
this is north horror I'm swimming around
in a vagina I'm swimming around in a
vagina I'm swimming around the nav
Aegina I tried
mm-hmm that was beautiful thank you
Prezi applause hmm thank you Oh next
week I have a an important project that
could change the world I can't say what
it is yet
secret but don't miss next week but yeah
that's pretty much it for this week I'll
be burped enjoyed stay awesome thanks
for all the things that you do for me
and I'll be sure to keep on making this
video anyway okay oh [ __ ] I have a new
camera and you set up and stuff like
that so yeah I'm not really used to
everything yeah but Farrah every week
every brofist I don't know what that was
about it sounded deep so I'm gonna do it
are you ready bros don't think you're
too too cool to broke this I bet you're
sitting like I'll just just totally lame
I'm not gonna brush my screen do it do
it do it okay on three
three no way one two
[Music]